ما عدا نشيد بوركينا فاسو يدوي في ارجاء
واسعه من اراضيها
[موسيقى]
وتوارى من السماء بعض قراها هذا العلم منذ
سنوات
فقد انحسرت سيطره عن مناطق في شمال وغرب
البلاد واشتدت وطاه الازمات الامنيه
والاقتصاديه
وفي ظل تصاعد هذه الازمات اشاحت بوركينا
فاسو بوجهها عن فرنسا واسوه
يممتكو بحثا عن الخلاص
غرب العاصمه ب 150 كيلومترا تتبدى اسباب
هذا الغضب والاحباط
في هذه القرى احكم الياس والقلق قبضتهما
على افئده الناس
يهاجم مسلحون هذه المناطق باستمرار
ودون ان تتدخل السلطات في بعض الاحيان
[موسيقى]
ابدا فيه نغادر بلدتنا لاننا لا نملك
وسائل للدفاع عن انفسنا وقد قتل المسلحون
جيراننا
وفي هذا المخيم الواقع على اطراف العاصمه
وجادو تتجرع مئات الاسر مراره النزوح
والام الضياع
اوضاع امنيه وانسانيه صرعتها على اثرها
لعقد اتفاقيه عسكريه تسمح بالشقوات فرنسيه
على اراضيها لكنها تضع رساله منطقه الساحل
لم تعد كما الف اهل
احتلالهم بهذه البلدان قبل سته عقود
كانت الاضطرابات الامنيه حينها قبل سبع
سنوات قد بدات تعصف بالاستقرار الهشي
للبلاد
ارسلت باريس 400 جندي من القوات الخاصه
الى وكادوغو وتعززت دور العسكري لفرنسا
اكثر في البلاد
وفي عمومي منطقه الساحل كانت فرنسا تكثف
حضورها العسكريه من خلال عمليه برخان وهي
عمليه كانت تشمل منطقه الساحل قبل ان
تغادر القوات الفرنسيه دوله
عسكري يمتد في عموم انحاء القاره
الافريقيه فمن جيبوتي شرقا الى شواطئ
الاطلسي في السنغال وكوت ديفوار والجابون
تحتفظ فرنسا بقوات بريه وبحريه وجويه
اضافه الى قاعده مايوت الخاضعه لسياده
الفرنسيه
ودارت السنوات هناك دون ان تخف حده
الاضطرابات الامنيه بل الطرمات اكثر مع
الايام
هدمت موجهه الانقلابات العسكريه الاخيره
اسس روابط قويه ظلت باريس تحتفظ بها مع
بعض هذه البلدان
وبدا وكان الحضور الفرنسيه يفقد ما كان له
ذات يوم هنا من بريق
يرى الناس هذه الانعطافه نحو روسيا وليس
للامر علاقه بالتوجهات السياسيه بالضروره
ولكن ما دامت بعض البلدان لا تمنحنا
الاسلحه فاننا سنتوجه الى بلدان اخرى
صداقه توطدت ايام حكم النقيب ثم صنكر
منتصف الثمانينيات وذاك زمن من فك يطل
بشخصه واحلامه ويستدعيه الناس هنا كلما
اضنهم الازمات الامنيه وشرف العيش
وجدت مالي في التوجه نحو روسيا التي لا
تول اهتماما كبيرا لقضاء حقوق الانسان
والتناوب والديمقراطيه حلا من نوع ما وهذا
هو النموذج الذي تتبعه السلطات في بوركينا
فاسو حاليا فخلال السنوات الاخيره وسعت
روسيا حضورها في القاره السمراء بدءا
بجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى عام 2018
وهو التعاون الذي اغرى وجده بالتوجه هي
الاخرى نحو موسكو
توسع انحسر على وقعه الحضور العسكري
لباريس في هذه المنطقه
جوله لم تكسبها فرنسا على الاقل في هذه
البلدان لكن خساره معركه لا تعني خساره
الحرب
هكذا تحدث الرئيس الفرنسي الاسبق شارلد
وهكذا تضمد باريس ما لحق بها حتى الان من
جراح جراء هذا النزاع
باب الحرمه الجزيره